for us the exaggerated structures on
these insects are sort of an extreme and
end of the continuum the the
morphologies of these animals are almost
ridiculous and so it's hard to look at
that and not wonder how it's possible I
mean how could you build an animal like
that and have it survive and thrive and
actually function or persists as a
population for millennia when they look
that screwed up in that crazy so it's
some level we're interested in them
because we're interested in diversity
and these are some of the extremes of
morphological diversity that you find
anywhere and so in our case we usually
study rhinoceros beetles with really big
horns but most of us are working in one
way or another on the development in the
evolution of these exaggerated
structures the weapons in these beetles
so the concepts in the in the backdrop
the behavior in the meeting system is
generalizable but we're also learning
that the genetics and the details of the
mechanisms are generalizable too so a
big part of what we've done recently is
to look at how nutrition influences the
growth of these big structures and why
it is that high nutrition translates
into a really big weapon and so the real
benefit to the big weapons is those
males guard the key real estate and
because they have the key real estate
they mate with the most females in the
populations but there's definitely
evidence that big males are more likely
to win fights and among size match males
the males with the largest horns are the
most likely to win fights but just like
we see in the field in our battle box
the males are fighting over food sources
and fighting over females and they use
their horn to like flick off the
opponent and try and get them away but
in the battle box the the loser doesn't
really go away very far so keep fighting
so so these are weapons they're used by
males and fights over over access to
females so as a structure they're
analogous in every
back to antlers that you'd see in deer
or elk or any of the charismatic sort of
megafauna with weapons except in this
case we can study them in ways they
can't study with I mean it's very hard
to do a genetic breeding experiment on
elk or on bison but with these guys we
can room in the laboratory so we can
start to look at the the nitty-gritty
sort of opening the car and looking
under the hood and finding out the
details of how these amazing structures
both form during development and change
over time through the process of
evolution it's a big part of what we do
just sort of bringing a variety of
different approaches to bear on these
crazy structures to look at how they
evolve and why they evolve